to certain states yeah I've been
[ __ ] on Connecticut for years of you
had low back you're shooting on
Connecticut gets to meet people come up
to me and they're like I'm talking like
in a coffee shop somewhere why does Joe
hate Connecticut next week yes yeah
feigus we're gonna be there son
oh I'm in Connecticut hosting ESPN
SportsCenter breaking down the fights
you got Connecticut and that it get
Bristol that would say they've grown up
put a bowl in the back of your head like
we did to Martin Luther King and Rosa
Parks like me me John School where we
would part of the country Stanford High
School in Connecticut okay that's a
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's a total [ __ ]
yeah especially the people like
Connecticut Connecticut is a [ __ ]
strange you got people around the edges
that are near Boston or that are in Rye
New York that are cool they look kind of
like yeah I didn't want to live in the
city I like I want a yard so they go to
Connecticut right and then you got those
[ __ ] deep weirdos I did one of the
casinos a few years back we did uh you
know weekend at the casino
and I was like I don't ever want to
[ __ ] do this again this is horrible
one of those one of those Indian casinos
I was like this is this place is [ __ ]
depressing these people are like what
you want to do next time but I mean this
don't get me wrong some nice people
there but they're all dying to get out
I think Connecticut's the worst though
who's Connecticut's depressing to me but
there's something depressing about
Connecticut where like Connecticut
always feels like there's no hope and
Hartford West surprisingly shitty I know
you think of Hartford Connecticut it
sounds regal well I used to work in all
over Connecticut when I was doing
stand-up I would drive from Boston into
Connecticut I did like a lot of gigs in
Hartford I did gig Hartford is a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
I grew up in New England in cold country
where in Connecticut uh-oh we're in
Connecticut that's not a Hartford okay
you're one of those people is it would
be the one look we all designated this
this place we meet we [ __ ] each other up
what's date yeah Connecticut Connecticut
yeah yeah states are problematic so then
what is people like [ __ ] Utah this is
Texas
son that's true yes I grew up in New
Jersey and New York aided us and [ __ ]
hates everybody hey boss Sylvania oh
yeah you hated Pennsylvania New York
hated Boston Connecticut got a pass okay
so it was like some little kid with a
limp like I don't pick on listen yeah I
think there's some resilience in living
in Connecticut too weird and plus it's
not really a state Connecticut's like my
way between New York and Boston in July
of 24 23 tree Playhouse in Connecticut
and the 25th cancel the kinetic Columbus
theatre Providence Rhode Island cancel
all Connecticut gigs why is that I
always do just for that I don't work in
Connecticut I'm not kidding it's not a
real estate okay highway I'm gonna
figure that out
- highway between Boston and New York
like it doesn't feel like a real state
it feels like a highway between Boston
and New York
I thought Connecticut was New Hampshire
Hot Chilli years and years look
Connecticut is a highway it's a highway
between Boston in New York spoken like a
poet Connecticut saw what everyone
connect it's like [ __ ] you
they are like [ __ ] you but you know what
[ __ ] you know I'm right yeah I'm not a
big fan of going to Connecticut but the
bottom line is Connecticut is filled
with despair yeah it's not a real state
it's a highway between New York and
Boston you know it's a highway
you guys put houses on a highway this is
what it is it's a highway and then along
the highway it's a bunch of [ __ ] tax
sheltering [ __ ] that uh that live in
Manhattan and then have these palatial
estates in everybody I know they grew up
in a tough neighborhood they have a
sharpness to them you know and there's a
character that they have that they
possess that the people that grew up
super cushy and some you know
Connecticut Country Club estate
situation I'm gonna let you know if
that's true don't do it but as of now
talk later
after that you like oh my god you were
so right the Connecticut gig was
horrible I need Connecticut people to
show me he's wrong all these Connecticut
people are mad at me now I get emails
from Connecticut bro
how about layoffs [ __ ] Connecticut
how about drive to Boston to drive to
New York and recognize [ __ ] you doing
but he lives in Connecticut uh-huh
interesting place don't live out all the
places to go you're from Brazil you
moved to Connecticut I wonder why these
nice
what yeah you live in my parents at a
house in Connecticut for ten years to
one of the few places I never perform it
yep house an inside joke people getting
mad people from Connecticut are sending
me messages come on broom I was banging
this girl once yeah back in the dizzay
when I was 20 and she's the first girl
to ever call her [ __ ] a [ __ ] and I want
you to [ __ ] me Mike I was like whoa
hello this girl's crazy she was one of
those nether-regions girls she was like
the Wildings you know the wild things
were and the game with Game of Thrones
yeah I know those people that lived out
in the the land between the kingdoms
right
she lived in Connecticut which is my
math that's where the wild things live
she was just like she really she was
joking she was so crazy I went to the
bathroom once and she gave my friend or
phone number like immediately this is
after I've already been having sex with
her I had sex with her that day and she
gave my friend or phone OH
she was crazy Mob Wives and Real
Housewives of New Jersey just to let me
know how happy I am that I don't have to
[ __ ] any of those monsters that I don't
have to date any of those New York New
Jersey Boston Connecticut those Beast
women those ethnic beast women I
remember I [ __ ] bombed in Connecticut
not in Connecticut and Pennsylvania
wants the whole thing was like what's
going on here what are you doing man you
know I'm from Philly and that story
happened in pencil you know outside of
Philadelphia it was Connecticut sure
thing is in Philly that was it's outside
for its power oh wow confused but it
wasn't John deep on this planet so I'm
not quick to call it planet 9 because so
far it's 20,000 times farther away from
the Sun than the earth is so I'm not
sorry you're not sorry I'm not feeling
like calling Connecticut New York City
I'm not feeling it so your your your
belief is that you're dealing with the
Pacific Northwest primarily and then
possibly a few other spots like
Connecticut
down the backside of the Appalachia New
England states damn etiquette
Connecticut well could be that's really
I don't really hate Connecticut one of
my best friends was in Connecticut
shoutout to Tommy jr. I don't really
hate Connecticut I
talking [ __ ] you gotta understand yeah
and by the way if you get like real
sensitive about your state you might be
a [ __ ] idiot
[Music]